what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we're gonna watch
my buddy 3c films chris his video
godzilla versus kong
first look at mechagodzilla and why
godzilla goes bad
reveal believe there was like some
information reveal from a set visit
chris one of the
times i actually discovered his channel
like way back when was when he was
covering godzilla versus kong stuff
before there was ever
any real footage and everything is one
of my go-to channels for
gvk information so yeah let's check it
out
oh yeah this is what i feel like
oh my god it's not what it looks like
it's like your father hey godzilla boys
oh chris we are so close to seeing this
perfect lizard come to battle and
basically all the mysteries surrounding
this movie have now been solved what i'm
gonna be bringing down here for you guys
is comicbook.com went ahead and did a
set visit where they actually got to be
on the set of godzilla vs kong shake
hands
with godzilla pluck them hairy cheeks oh
i'm so jealous but not only that they
spoke to production designers the
directors and
basically all our fan theories are going
to be put to shame right now
because they explain right tongue is
much bigger in this movie where he
everybody
why godzilla goes bad in this movie and
even
our first look oh
how do you feel about all these
explanations involved in the movie even
if you don't enjoy them like
we're really watching this thing to just
see two gigantic things battle it out
and we's gonna get that as well as don't
be picking and hit that like button and
subscribing if you're enjoying it do it
related content so like i said here
comicbook.com we're the ones who went
ahead and did a set visit and basically
revealing all these details here i'll go
one by one with it so
for one they do go ahead and explain why
kong is much bigger in this movie and
it's kind of something we've already
been knowing they go ahead and said here
kong is bigger in this film there's a
line of schooling yeah that he's still
growing
so he's an adolescent in that film not
only that they also seem to confirm
where kong is going to be getting his
gigantic battle axe in this movie to
fight godzilla they go ahead and say
here a second mission is commissioned to
go into hollow earth
but it's much more dangerous journey
nathan who at first is resistant is
eventually through some very emotional
means convinced to go
he stole that they have new crafts for
this journey into hollow earth through
this different portal but nathan only
agrees to go
if they take kong with him the belief is
that if they have a creature they
believe came from hollow earth
it's probably a smart play to consider
there will be all sorts of monsters in
the film
especially in the hollow earth sequence
whoa whoa whoa whoa
hold on a second let's slow this down
all right so the footage that we've been
seeing that
kind of looks like oh is that skull
island or not when it came to getting
the battle axe a lot of us were thinking
that he might get it from the hollow
earth they just clarify it here
and it sounds like alexander skarsgard's
character
is actually very important and vital to
getting this axe for being able to go
into the hollow earth
because you know a lot of times with
these characters you're like ah you're
kind of dumb or we don't really need
them they're
kind of boring at least to hear what
they're saying is a big part of what
allows kong to get his axe
relies on alexander skarsgard's nathan
leading the charge into hollow earth and
it's cool they've created some new
new equipment and be able to go in there
kong's just there to be like
he's cool they're with us yeah and we
saw in the trailer that's where kong
went ahead and grabbed his battle axe
and put it up to the sky
and that basically does confirm what
we've been hearing is that although the
axe is made out of a spike from a
godzilla
it's not the godzilla that we're seeing
in the movie it was made by his
ancestors
and passed down because godzilla and
kong that is
yeah throw the plot out there because
they say here the belief is if they have
a creature they believe came from hollow
earth and who will have some kingship
with some of the things they may find
in it they may have a better chance to
survive so some of the things they might
find in it
is going to be that battle x but also
that's some of the stuff uncovering the
mechagodzilla in this movie they confirm
they are using the ghidorah head though
whoa
they just go out there away
kind of haunts this movie going on to
what the production designer then says
no one had ever really designed the
ghidorah skull continuing on somehow the
ghedora skull will be tied directly
connected to the mechagodzilla of it all
we all kind of figured that's what they
would be doing with that ghidorah head
is kind of using it as the blueprints to
make mechagodzilla i know there were
some fans out there that were really
hoping that it was mega ghidorah but
not just yet maybe at the end of this
movie they could find the godzilla head
and turn that into mega godora but also
since now we know
i mean it's kind of surprising that they
would reveal this on a set visit it's
not like all this information's been
coming out and people have been
theorizing and then they're like you
know what yeah everyone's gonna
no everyone's already figured it out
might as well just talk about it which
in itself would have been a bummer as it
is but to know that they just kind of
revealed this on a set visit which was a
long time ago [ __ ] still give two shits
about we're giving all this away
i guess unless they have some kind of
other crazier surprise that no one's
thinking or talking about or that hasn't
even been alluded to in these trailers
or something it is a little surprising
for them to be like yeah let's explain
the nature of
how this rumor is going to take place
but i like the idea of like
godora is kind of a thing that lingers
and haunts over
all of this considering that ghidorah
you know is that actually not an og
titan that godor is an alien
so well i know i don't know if that has
anything to get out of our planet
this also explains why godzilla is going
bad in this movie right here in the
article they say
this ghidorah skull will send out some
sort of signal out in godzilla versus
kong which will be a key part of the
film which allows the incredibly
disgusting show to show off
its gotcha that is finally the
explanation we have right there is
godzilla
is right there in the trailer it's not
the theory that some of us had where we
thought that wasn't really godzilla and
maybe
it was inspiration from the touhou
movies where it's mecha godzilla in
disguise
or a hologram covering him up nope that
actually is godzilla the
entire time he's just kind of going
crazy and mad because
he hears a signal of ghidorah out there
and he has no idea where it's coming
from this also explains why in the
trailer we see a board that is only
attacking apex and monarch locations
because he's looking for this skull that
is probably being moved around to all
these locations
and you know what that seems like a good
explanation and it makes sense why the
king of monsters would want to finish
the job he started but like still
godzilla is still
killing innocent people for this thing
are we absolvers kong fans gonna be able
to forgive that
as our kingdom our savior is just doing
that it's almost like a
okay so that makes sense with the
ghidorah skull being out there and
sending out the signal godzilla's coming
here i don't know how i feel about that
with
i kind of wanted godzilla to come here
specifically to fight kong
yeah it's starting to seem like kong's
here to fight godzilla whereas
godzilla's like
you're in my way that's always freaking
out
of relief i'm not here to fight you i'm
here to fight kedora and i can't
see him big electric nightmare bat hydra
monster somewhere in here
godzilla's just got ptsd from last time
and he wants a rest
yeah i mean we'll see how it plays out
in the movie because yeah now it's
seeming more about like
hurrying up to get to godzilla to
fighting ghidorah again or this you know
fake make a godzilla
mech slash mechagadora combination of
sorts i personally just from an
expectation standpoint
wanted it to be like no he's coming back
here to fight kong specifically
and this goes in tune with some of the
theories that we've heard will it really
feel like the movie's about godzilla
versus kong at this point or are they
just having these fights in between
them having to eventually team up to
take on mechagodzilla yeah
this seems like it's going will this be
sort of hampered by the need to
keep the franchise moving and not yeah
taint
the sort of protagonist element we've
established with godzilla i feel like
the older ones they would sort of teeter
back and forth where it's like he had
somewhere godzilla's just the villain
somewhere godzilla's not the villain
yeah and
i i don't get the sense that they're
very keen on doing that here
that's the big mystery to me now is just
what is going to be the purity of
godzilla versus
kong and how will that figure into the
greater picture with all the
titans yeah so it's being revealed here
i know it's almost like a winter soldier
situation where the winter soldier is a
good guy but he's had all this
mind manipulation that led him to kill
tony stark's parents
along with so many other assassinations
are we going to be okay once that all
goes away
still being tricked into killing people
though who killed my cousin larry he was
working in the farms but maybe they'll
explain
that godzilla was only attacking apex
locations and that that's the bad guy
headquarters so it's okay he killed bad
guys but along with the seventh exactly
we also have the photos itself of our
first look of the inside of
mechagodzilla
and here you go this thing is a beaut i
am loving the vibe
inside this head this will be the
control base for the mechagodzilla it
sort of has a pacific
rim style vibe yeah it's also got a
doctor who tardis
right which is kind of surprising to me
because i thought it would be something
where a human would safely be miles away
controlling the mechagodzilla
because he was standing in front of
those blueprints of the mechagodzilla i
really can't wait to see the explanation
for why they went ahead and did this
where they actually want to be
protectors of earth so they were wanting
to use this thing to kind of rule over
the world and be like look if we have a
mechanical godzilla nobody can take us
down and then i can have all the pokemon
cards in the world because that
that's what the movie's about right i
can understand some people thinking this
is a big spoiler for godzilla versus
kong scene
yes absolutely but we all kind of
figured
the dude would be showing up in the
movie because come on all these versus
films
have had some guy show up that's a third
party that the other two guys have to
team up and fight
that's pretty fascinating that there's
actually a human inside there
yeah like how they get to that point
with technology where they would feel
safe enough to be
inside here while tight when they're
fighting another titan or something or
godzilla itself no matter what you build
damn how do you get to that point what i
love just the idea of them going inside
this giant biological skull and being
like okay how where do we put like the
cockpit
where we put the scenes and the controls
and all that and also is this going to
be like a
a single manned vehicle or is this going
to be like a like a battle [ __ ] like an
enterprise yeah
there's several decks like it seems like
it would be a hard place to do work just
given all the motion
but yeah man oh wow okay so there's
someone in there i mean
we've been wanting a pacific rim and
godzilla crossover or
a monster crossover with pacific rim for
a while now i mean
if in the monster verse they are at the
point where they're able to build
some type of jaeger in the form of a
disguise of a titan
of a kaiju then i feel like we're almost
there
we're slowly getting there also pair
that up with the confusing marketing
message that one will fall in this movie
promising either godzilla or
kong at least that's what we think we
all know it's gonna be mechagodzilla as
the one who falls
the director was still pretty open with
collider saying that he wasn't gonna
make the same mistakes batman vs
superman did in this whole two people
fighting that then have to meet a
separate villain so
i have faith that they can pull it off
and i'm thinking there's still going to
be a couple more surprises left in here
in this movie
so even with us seeing the inside of
what mega godzilla is going to be
looking like i still want to know
what it could mean for the larger
monster universe and how they're even
gonna end this movie if they're gonna
continue making more monster universe
movies
i mean it still is like a bbs thing
because in the nbs people act like
there's no declared winner batman won
that fight
and then they go after doomsday and lex
and all that
there's no one died in the fight i don't
know excited for it that's the funny
thing about this now is they seem to be
doubling down on all these things that
seem to go against that claim of no no
no it's gonna be a legit fight between
these two and one's gonna win but
there's all this
other stuff that i still wonder if
they're maybe not
quite telling us the full truth or maybe
misleading us
in some way into anybody questioning
that this would even be involved with
mechagodzilla since they weren't clear
to say that in the article even though
it's super obvious if you peek yourself
into the very corner of this photo you
can see again
the control panel for a mecha godzilla
right there if you zoom into it so
don't know what else this could be used
for but i think it'll still make sense
in the movie and it'll be cool to see
then once mechagodzilla comes stepping
out of course that signal he's sending
out is going to deter godzilla's
attention from king kong
and turn around to want to beat up
mechagodzilla i also wonder if apex is
knowing about this signal that the
ghedorah head is sending out and maybe
they can weaponize it and have it be
pinpointed at a certain location where
they can then turn
godzilla into their own weapon where
they can fake a signal that it's coming
from florida then godzilla will come
over there
destroy some buildings or even them
targeted to king kong himself and make
him think
he's where the signal's coming from
the movie and in the end we're just
wanting to see these two guys fight each
other and that's going to be the best
part of the film
right here how they release this
international poster of godzilla and
kong
fighting in the water it doesn't make a
lot of sense for my boy kong really
trying to breathe under that water
but it looks like he does have the upper
hand on godzilla choking him right here
so
go kong but how are you guys feeling
about this explanation right here do you
like the reason that godzilla's
feel like i've laid it out how do you
feel about how king kong is getting his
axe do you like this pacific rim vibe
that they're giving mechagodzilla
anything and everything i want to hear
your guys thoughts down below don't
forget to like subscribe
follow mentor at 3c film review as
always i'm chris
take care take care chris great video
damn so much was revealed there i'm so
excited for it
as long as it's a fun movie as long as
it's a fun monster mayhem film and i've
been loving
uh revisiting the last three movies uh
within this franchise so
yeah i'm excited for it regardless and
most of it is
most of it is what we've been theorizing
you know what the theories we believe so
it's not a big deal
really and i gotta imagine there's
probably more that they're hiding if
they're okay with the drugs yeah i was
just a little surprised that they
confirmed so much yeah
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below check out our other gvk
videos and of course keep a look out for
when our
uh godzilla vs kong review is out if
we're lucky enough to get a reaction up
we will thank you chris
prince together take care